happy birthday America we're celebrating
our nation's independence with a
fun-filled show ahead including a
patriotic trivia challenge I will
definitely win just kidding who will be
crowned this year's Champion stay tuned
to find out we're facing off in a Fourth
of July edition of Supermarket Showdown
we're also going to answer your fan mail
questions and we have a brand new
segment for you we're looking back at
our fourth of July favorite memories but
first it's the five summer fun
extravaganza
[Music]
we're diving into some summer topics to
celebrate 4th of July first up butter up
your popcorn Hollywood summer
blockbuster season is in full swing
can I come to your house tonight
I don't have anything big planned just a
giant blowout party with all the
Barbie's and plant choreography and a
bespoke song you should stop by stop by
so cool why would we go to the middle of
nowhere
for who knows how long
why why
how about because this is the most
important thing that ever happened in
the history of the world and those are
just a couple of the big flick sitting
theaters so what's our all-time favorite
Blockbuster I guess we have some that
are coming out
um this summer maybe they will be our
favorite I know you were just saying in
the commercial break that Barbie you
cannot wait you know obviously he's a
big collector of the toys stop it uh the
Barbie movie looks goofy okay I don't
know that I'll see it I'll tell you what
I want to see but I feel like it's
guilty of false advertising is Mission
Impossible seven okay yeah is this
technically the eighth installment of
this film okay if they've pulled the
mission off the first seven times it's
not that impossible
mission fairly difficult but you never
know okay but I'm excited to see it
because he does his own stunts and he's
he's a gangster okay and of course
there's a reboot of my favorite summer
blockbuster series of all time which is
Indiana Jones starring Harrison Ford who
I love uh there's a little more CGI in
this one from what I've told it's more
like Temple of Zoom because he's not
really there for most of stunts but I
think it's going to be a banger I'm
looking forward to those two Jessica we
a lot of us turn to you for our
entertainment recommendations what do
you have on your list well I'm so
psyched about Barbie
yes yeah okay I so I love Ryan Gosling
and I love Margot Robbie and Greta
Gerwig is a champion everything that
she's done I think is fantastic and
they're making such incredible fun of
Barbie and the Ridiculousness of this
doll set and this world that it seems
obviously dumb but also very smart like
I love um if in one of the promos they
get arrested and Ryan Gosling's holding
up his name plate and it says and Ken
because he was never Ken right it was
just Barbie and Ken and they say
girlfriend boyfriend which is my
favorite thing anyway I'm excited about
that but Independence Day was my
favorite all time I think I remember
going with my parents to see
Independence Day when it first yeah yeah
I remember like it was yesterday what
about you judge
um you know I don't have a favorite from
this list I mean I'd like to see uh
first of all Barbie uh it's that's not
one of the ones I'm gonna see I
don't know
me neither no
what I celebrate I think like a Fourth
of July would be Top Gun you know to me
that's kind of a you know go get em
um and that would probably be my
favorite Fourth of July movie okay on
this list
Little Mermaid is your favorite those
Kitty well you know I'm waiting for it
to come out at home because I'm a little
bit cheap and lazy that way so it's not
going to come out till September for me
uh but the two that I've really honed in
on the most are Oppenheimer and Barbie
because they come out on my birthday
and those two really are like two sides
of my personality you know a whole bunch
of pink some war and bombs like that's
really just sums me up can you tell us
one thing that you said in the break
which I think is great you've watched
The Notebook yeah we know the run the
Ron Gosling connection here I'm a big
fan of Margot Robbie and pretty much
anything she does
I just think she's an incredibly
talented
Ryan Gosling uh I only will ever know
him as Noah the dude who who's a
Carpenter and he's poor and he steals
the heart of some rich girl and she
treats him like complete garbage his
whole life but he loves her anyway he
even has kids with her and then he Dives
right beside her I think that's a cool
movie I watched it with a bunch of
Marines in Iraq when I watched it and we
all walked away from that going man she
was horrible she was terrible
she came around but do you know do you
know why men are crying during the
notebook it's because he was banking
after them being married for 60 years on
getting his single life back for a few
years yeah but now they die on the same
day treats him bad and yeah even in old
age she's like I don't even know who you
are I just I do love the image of all
the Marines watching The Notebook
all right up next everyone loves a good
summer vacation but please take your
time when packing one in five people say
that they always realize they forgot to
pack something after they've arrived top
items we leave at home include water
bottles who leaves that deodorant
sunscreen a hat often you forget your
hat judge you travel a lot do you forget
anything I travel all the time the one
thing I always forget and never remember
is a comb there's something about a comb
that's just never there for me but I do
Pat you know what I do I pack things for
one overnight and then something for two
overnights right so I just pull that out
I pull that package out and it goes
right in the suit let's put a comb in
that bag yeah you know without it
Jessica
sunscreen but it's intentional because
of the TSA rules I really struggle with
this like any good sunscreen I know they
make like the mini ones now but
regulations giving you cancer I love
that we've gotten to a government
right here in the air but it's so
expensive when you buy it wherever
you're going it's like forty dollars for
it and so I'm always like please don't
take it away you get the sunscreen wipes
are those good yeah sure like they don't
dry up before it gets from the box to
your skin no I don't think so all right
problem solved all right what about you
oh I'm a professional traveler because
I'm on the right stand up um this is
what I've noticed the things people
forget are the things you can get when
you get there what's on that list it's
like deodorant toothpaste you can get
that you're not supposed to forget the
big thing so to me big things if you go
to the beach you're going on the road I
need to speak a Bluetooth speaker have
you seen my ACT I'm kidding not quite
Magic Mike it's tragic Mike but the
point is there's a lot of chubby chasers
out don't tell me sure uh Bluetooth
speaker charger phone uh I have a basic
standard outfit I wear when I travel why
because as a Fox News personality I
realized about a year ago that you're
going to be in a lot of pictures you
didn't know you were going to be in and
one day I was at LaGuardia I was taking
a picture with a guy he's like this is
going on my fridge and I was like oh my
God I'm probably at a thousand fridges
dressed like a circus clown so now I
pack a little more efficiently okay all
right what about you you travel a lot
yeah you know I do travel I just came
back back from a cruise and it's not
what I forget to bring on vacation with
me it's what I forget to bring that day
and leave in the hotel room when you go
on a cruise you get off the boat well
you know you're not going to be back to
your stuff until you get back on the
boat so what am I forgetting sunglasses
sunscreen pretty much everything you
need to get off a boat on a cruise I
left in the room and it's like is it
worth going so then you have four pairs
of sunglasses at the end of the oh
that's true the things I have bought on
vacation that I already owned at home or
why a clutter okay I want to tell you
this story about something I thought I'd
forgotten okay so I go to this
conference in Montana every year and we
go out there Peter and I go together
and one year we get there and it's hard
to pack for because there's lots of
different things there's uh there's like
a outdoor component there's an evening
thing and you know these things and
there's the sessions so I have my cowboy
boots and I put all my undergarments in
the cowboy boots right yeah now I pack
like five days before because I was
really busy whatever so we get to
Montana we're unpacking and I'm like
and Peter says what I said I I don't
have any undergarments and I'm panicking
literally panicking there's one store in
this Tiny Town
and I'm like what am I going to do what
I'm gonna do and I was almost in tears
we got a huge fight I thought it was his
fault because I'm supposed to lay
everything out and then he was going to
pack it in the thing and at the last
minute he said something like wait did
you put it in the shoes I'm like oh
there they were they were my cowboy
boots
I've never told that story out loud okay
up next crank up the radio a good Summer
music playlist is always essential for a
good time and you know I'm tuned into
the country station but what other songs
are we into this season gotta go to you
Joey what do you like uh way down the
under on the Chattahoochee is the is
for Joey Jones that's my thing
I'm still in a Taylor Swift okay because
I have not gone to the concert and I now
realize also that the prices will never
drop
um so Taylor Swift and the Miley the new
Miley Cyrus yeah but I always think of
summer as kind of throwback yes like old
songs versus I get it that things are
songs in the summer and like Dua lipa's
had a few amazing ones but I like
listening to stuff I know all the words
to in the summer I was at a wedding
where they the Joe barracata band in New
Jersey covered the Miley Cyrus Miley
Cyrus Flower Song and they were
fantastic
yeah I love I love Miley Cyrus and I
like the new song also uh last night
Morgan Whalen that's
about it
co-signed the judge on Morgan Wallen
last night because I don't listen to a
lot of current stuff what I listen to is
Highway music the summer it's a road
trip summer that's where you go so I'm
listening to a lot of like Leonard
Skynyrd Mr Breeze they call me the
breeze that jam I like that a lot ZZ Top
Sharp Dressed Man which is now sharp
just them but stick with me still a good
song but I like a lot of those jams and
I really like uh on the highway
specifically like 80s retro that's what
you said Throwbacks Tears for Fears
Everybody Wants To Rule The World is a
great 80 mile an hour song I think
that's how you do it it's the best song
on the Guardians of Galaxy ride thank
you very well said my favorite summer
song right now is gold by Dierks Bentley
followed by sunsets in Colorado by
Dierks Bentley wow and I could go on
there are more are they all Dierks are
all really good mine used to be
Summertime by Will Smith but it makes
the comedians I'm traveling with think
I'm gonna smack them so I can't play it
anymore Kenny Chesney summer last year
it's a Dirk's one this year all right
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else